welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is shibashi Chatterjee the fulbright
Niro visiting professor at the Macmillan
Centre and a professor at jet report
University in India his research
interests include international
relations Theory foreign policy and
security policy in South Asia today
we'll talk with professor Chatterjee
about his forthcoming book power and
territoriality India's imagination of
South Asia
welcome professor Chatterjee thank you
very much Marlene it's really a pleasure
to be here thank you let's begin with an
overview of your book tell us about it
well the book is as you rightly said it
states tentatively tale you know titled
as say to reality in South Asia which
basically looks at how India became Cato
realized and what they to realize
sovereignty does to India's foreign
policy in its immediate neighborhood
which is broadly speaking South Asia so
what I intend to sort of do in this book
is that I look at space and I define
space let's say very broadly as three
possible configurations so you can have
spaces power you can also define space
as a marketplace which is basically
spaces Commerce and you can also define
space as a meta community of sorts so
the hypothesis of my book is that for
reasons that I explained in the text
Indian foreign policy decision makers
have always viewed and this is also sort
of in a way I think extendable to South
Asian elites as a whole so what I argue
in the book would not only hold true for
India would also be true for other South
Asian states so the foreign policy elite
in India they define space in South Asia
as a space of power rather than spaces
market
space has community so that's the broad
I mean sort of argument which I have and
the follow-up argument I make is that
this is obviously not an inevitable sort
of development there are reasons as to
why South Asia in fact is a zone of
power or a space of power which is
broadly sort of explained by the fact
that the underlying models of politics
that prevail in South Asia they're of a
particular kind so I make the argument
that if the nature of politics in South
Asia changes then the conceptualization
of South Asia as a space in fact would
also change so one of the arguments that
I'm making here is this that we need to
pay more attention to the way in which
speciality in fact is configured in the
area rather than sort of looking at how
you know one or two states they converse
daily with each other
I'm not saying in the text in the book
that this conversation in fact is
unimportant but what I'm saying is that
relations tend to move between certain
fixed terms of references and they're
predicated on certain condition a letís
and my text is about eliminating these
conditionalities and predications I mean
so that's what broadly the text is
that's really interesting I mean sort of
question I find I guess there are two
motivations Merlion first is that you
know I was intrigued by two very
different genre of writing you know on
Indian foreign policy and South Asian
politics one of these in fact are
writings by really scholars who are
broadly that's interested on questions
of power and military strategy let's say
and the write on issues like India's
rise is a great power what that rise in
fact you know what kind of impact that
rise would have in terms of India's rich
what kind of power projections India is
capable of making in the short run and
also in the long run perhaps and also
things like you know indicated
of national power okay this could be
military capability nuclear weapons
massage satellite you know capability
and also broadly let's a sort of
economic various economic indicators
that I think run into any definition of
national power
in contrast sharp contrast in fact to it
in fact is a very critical body of
literature that in fact has gradually
sort of lets accumulated over the years
this is in the absence of of an angry
term described as a kind of a critical
post-colonial literature on indian state
making Indian foreign policy and
security policy these this body of
literature in fact looks at some of the
constitutive principles of the
subcontinent
what made us I mean why is it that
sovereignty in fact has taken a
particular cast in South Asia we could
have been something else okay but the
way in which we relate to each other's
some of the political principles and
institutions that we have and some of
the major challenges in fact which we
face existential in particularly in the
domains of politics and security they
need a kind of a historical sociological
hero analysis which questions some of
the things that the realists and others
in fact would take it for granted the
problem that I've faced while reading
this literature in fact is that these
two you know bodies of work they never
talked to each other okay so they there
is a conversation of enough salt but
that conversation is at each other but
not to each other relaxing so one of the
reasons that I wanted to write the text
in fact is you know way to begin that
kind of a conversation yes yes yes you
know not necessarily because I want to
buy media of sorts not necessarily
because I wish to in a way sort of
reduce the distance or anything because
I think these are principled positions
of I think opposition let's say you know
and I I don't think a kind for
compromise is possible but conversation
is is
definitely I mean sort of possible so
therefore I agree with the relays that
the security issues are real and I also
agree with the post-colonial and the
critical energy onre that Hmong need to
have been sort of one needs to plumb
deeper and oneness to sociology eyes and
problematize some of these categories
okay with a critical sort of let's say
you know trajectory so my problem with
the really scholarship in fact is that
the realists in fact would take almost
virtually everything for granted okay
the problem with the critical
scholarship on the other hand is that
they would often leave a problem there
you know in other words they will
critique but beyond the critique there
is virtually nothing I mean if you say
for example that ok you know if you are
territorial eyes then you ought a toriel
eyes that doesn't really help ok I mean
because we are tutorial eyes and I don't
think that the unbundling of data really
is something that is going to happen
nobody's going to give up sovereignty or
something of that sort so therefore I
think it's only responsibility on you
know on you know it's one of the
responsibilities those colors I mean
that we need to at least analytically
have something more here you know which
might in some way or the other percolate
to policymakers because my text is
essentially not a policy friendly kind
of attacks but I do feel that you know
it would in a way open up the space
between the academic writings on one
hand and the policy making discourses on
the other because I feel that unless you
understand what exactly you you know you
wish to do in life you can't even
experiment with alternative
possibilities and I know you know being
here at Yale you've had access to some
of the resources here so tell us about
it and first yale had been simply
fascinating okay i mean the kind of
resources that i had been able to draw
from the library in fact has been
absolutely mind-boggling and the problem
with Indian and
libraries had been that it's basically a
problem with positive resources I guess
I mean particularly in a place like
Kolkata I mean like just or or you know
project news and other resources that we
have I mean they don't even have 135 a
say of the kind of journals and all
which a place like Yale in fact would
subscribe to so it's been incredibly
beneficial
well the methodological part of it is in
a way and again a little bit intriguing
in the sense it look this book has been
in the making for a long time and if a
project is actually having sort of
happening for a long time it has both
advantages and disadvantages possibly
more disadvantages than advantages but
one of the advantage of the book being
in the making for a long time is that I
have been able to I think pack in a lot
of very interesting stuff which I would
possibly would not have been able to do
if I had completed writing the book
about maybe three four years back what
kind of interesting stuff like for
example you know there's a very
interesting body of work that has come
up in the last three four years which
looks at things like you know India
citizenship India's understanding of
migrations and borders it's very
interesting stuff which also looks at
how India relates to the Diaspora so did
this work in fact has opened up new
Vista okay even for conventional you
know sort of let's say geopolitical
analysis I'm very thankful that I
delayed my own work okay I mean
particularly to three books that I could
in my mind you know almost sort of close
my eyes and recall those have been very
very I mean sort of you know useful in
terms of I think benchmarking my texts
the method as a whole in fact is is a
straightforward body in the sense that
you know I mean I don't do any empirical
testing or anything of that sort because
my interest in international Asians is
broadly political Theory driven so as a
political scientist my specialization is
also in somewhere broadly political
theory in international Asians Theory
have always been an interface kind of a
person and say you know I've always
loved to read more political theory than
anything else but I've always written
more on South Asia and
try to sort of terrorize out this year
so the book uses conventional methods
like I mean sort of I did a lot of talk
with the foreign policy elite in India
I took interviews at conversations
exchanges I followed closely all the
public documents that they need document
in fact I released you can't really get
to files because he's a classified file
since India has one of the strictest and
so classification rules in the world
so unless of course you are trying to
sort of in a way you know get around the
problem through WikiLeaks and other I
mean sort of stuff that it's available
but then I haven't really looked into
those kind of self mats my book is more
about meaning than anything else I mean
so I'm basically looking at broad
political theory debates and
international agents debates for example
and see that how they impact on it you
can't really have a kind of let's say
meaningful ethnography of foreign policy
decision makers you know because foreign
policy is so high-end but on the other
hand you know you can know you can talk
to people on the ground and try to
understand that why by and large people
are not interested that much in foreign
policy issues in India although you know
in some way or the other foreign policy
do come to their life so I did a lot of
event sort of interesting interviewing
you know of people living on the border
and people living far away from the
border and also in differences
yeah there's a big difference huge
differences in perceptions I mean people
who are away from the border the border
doesn't really make much of a difference
international politics doesn't really
interest them so much
I mean international politics of South
Asia but if you were on the border
that's its existential virtually I mean
you know it impacts virtually on every
dimension of your life and there is also
an increasing fertilization of Indian
foreign policy you see I mean New Delhi
as the home of the Ministry of External
Affairs would decide most of foreign
policy issues however in the last few
years some of the provinces have become
more important
okay particularly when it comes to
deciding on you know neighborly issues
like for
you know they say that I come from the
spring goal when it comes to foreign
policy decision-making on Bangladesh
which being all in fact above one
exercise DeVito
the same is true of Tamilnadu in South
which in fact had had a very big impact
on India's see Lanka policy okay if
you're looking at Nepal a state like
Uttar Pradesh Bihar in fact you know
these states in fact have had impact on
how India in fact sort of relates to
Nepal so these things have happened of
late Pakistan is a bit I would say bit
been exceptional in the sense that if
you're looking at the neighboring states
is Punjab and Rajasthan broadly there's
a bit of Gujarat which is also I mean
sort of borders Pakistani but the the
federalism that we're witnessing right
now it's not really very strongly
influential in the making of Pakistan's
fall in a part India's Pakistan policy
that is primarily because of the
extraordinary geopolitical you know
competition that you have between the
two states but on the other hand when
you look at issues like how commercially
the two Punjab's relate to in panino in
Pakistan or in terms of some people to
be able contract in a context which
unfortunately in fact have come down
sadly enough I know in some in the
recent years there I think the province
is obviously played a big part
okay the to Punjab they're culturally
quite why why do I say quite a very very
close as to Bengals are for that matter
for that matter so metal so in terms of
method yes and as I said I mean so it's
basically a book that's based on
conventional analytical method and I
look at I look at published reports look
at news interviews and stuff like that
and then leave it to my analysis let's
talk about foreign policy India's
foreign policy imagination of South Asia
remains constant why do you think that
is
that in a way is what my book is are
giving Marley
you know which is that I find that even
if political power changes in India the
foreign policy orientation in South Asia
doesn't change okay with broadly I mean
I'm not basically making the argument
that you will not have any variation in
terms of bilateral ties okay because
bilateral ties are susceptible to almost
sort of let's say you know daily
developments okay but if you were
looking in terms of the cost of foreign
policy if you're looking in terms of the
quality of policy let's say there's a
remarkable degree of continuity there
and I read that continuity in the
constitution of the subcontinent itself
you know the fact that we became danger
realized with an obsessive attachment to
sovereignty reality it basically sort of
means that no state in fact is very
comfortable in fully opening itself up
to the other okay so the past to a large
extent looms on us and it looms on us in
manners that make us I think extremely
nervous yes the colonial past but the
the major point that I'm making here is
days that foreign policy seem to be
moving from one point to the other here
you know between fixed references and my
text is about explaining these fixed
references I mean my basic argument here
is this that unless you have a very
different kind of politics growing in
South Asia as a whole and particularly
in India which in fact would be I think
let's say confident enough of taking
risks I do not see any possibility of
any transformation in the underlying
ideas of foreign policy particularly
when it comes to India's foreign policy
in South Asia one of the facts that I am
looking at in fact is a very well known
you know what you call he's a very well
known fact you know which is that one of
the reasons why India in fact finds is
very difficult to grow as a power
is because it's because it's
neighborhood is fraught so you've been
living with it for more than 70 years
now okay and nothing seems to be
radically sort of changing a lot depends
on what kind of regime you have in the
other state so if you have a regime that
is friendly to you then relations
improve but the basic orientation
doesn't change okay that's my basic
argument and my point is that that
orientation is never going to change
unless we are ready to question some of
the heritage that we have and and how
would you question them what do you
think needs to happen for that to happen
oh I mean I think I've no doubt about it
which is the only way that we will be
able to question that is provided both
Democrats and provided both democracy
and liberal I and and and liberalism
become strong in South Asia okay
unfortunately I don't see that happening
democratization is obviously becoming
stronger in South Asia but strong
democracy doesn't necessarily mean a
culture of strong liberalism okay I mean
so the difficulty that I see in South
Asia in fact is that South Asia in fact
has never really been a liberal space
okay I mean India possibly had been more
liberal compared to many other
post-colonial states or many other third
world countries but Indian liberalism in
fact is a very you know again a deeply
divided kind of liberalism
so essentially you know it's that old I
would say contradiction between what's
important you know whether it's the
calculation of majoritarian
considerations of democracy when numbers
really you know seem to dominate or is
it really the prerogative of the
individual okay so the notions of
selfhood if you look at it closely I
think remain deeply deeply I mean sort
of let's say convoluted and debated in
the subcontinent as a whole and also in
India and particularly if you were
looking in you know in the last maybe
last one decade why one decade even two
decades let's say we find that Hindu
nationalists in fact of gaining ground
and a kind of cultural nationalism is
growing so my thesis is that's not
really my thesis but it's a call
only he'll believe I guess that as
cultural nationalism become stronger in
India a kind of conservative
anti-liberal communitarian project is
going to gain ground interesting so and
what do you mean by cultural yes what do
you mean by that actually Oh cultural
nationalism in fact is broadly let's say
a political paradigm which makes the
argument that if you want to regain your
position in the world you need to tidy
yourself
domestically ok so what is tidying up
tidying up would basically mean that you
need to homogenize so heterogeneity is
weakness so how do you tidy you tidy on
the basis of some of the old notions of
culture that in fact had brought
stability in India over the millennia
which is that you have a kind of a
hierarchical model which is very
coercive but hierarchical like the caste
system yes very much so which in fact
produces order but order at a great cost
okay which is coercion
now that project obviously has become
deeply contested in India okay with the
empowerment of the lower castes and
stuff like that but then those who are
pen during the cost of cultural and self
nationalism they're making the argument
that unless India regains some form of
homogeneity which they define in terms
of their Hindu nez and also in terms of
a political Hindutva which is not really
haven't sort of entirely synonymous with
what Hinduism means in religious terms
but unless India is able to do that
India's prospects of graduating as a
major power in fact is doomed
the problem with that idea is that it is
a complete antithesis of anything that
is remotely liberal right okay and the
second that this project in fact would
be deeply divisive and utterly
convulsive in its immediate
neighbourhood okay because some of these
problems in fact the source in the
neighborhood historically and my book
doesn't really discuss these things
because it's an excellent literature
that
exists on this right right now okay so
the historical part of how we became tej
realized how we were enumerated by the
institutions of modernity all these in
fact everyone's there okay so I don't
really write on that but how we take it
from there
the fact that we are thi realized and
now we have the prospect of this
cultural nationalism which is also
trying to draw in the Diaspora and some
of the exhibitionism of that which i
think you know was also apparent in the
election campaign so I think all these
are ominous portents if you ask me of
the kind of things that might happen in
a state like India which is not going to
compromise the Democratic you know
aspect of the equation but it's going to
definitely I think you know we can the
liberal side of the equation talk a
little bit about how your book is
different from the other texts that are
out there I mean you've kind of touched
upon it a little bit but go into a
little bit more I think my book would be
different in three ways one it's a book
which is not about India's rise as a
major power I'm not interested in that
question already a lot in fact has
written about it and I don't think that
I can really add anything you know what
is interesting there second my book is
not about bilateral relations of India
in the subcontinent so what is my book
about then my book the point of
departure of the text in fact is this
that I want to understand why despite
the fact that South Asians are
culturally one people by and large
so our shared cultural Heritage's in
fact are very well historically social
logically anthropologically documented
why do we end up producing so much so
much of political violence okay so if
cultural similarity at one hand on one
hand but you on the other hand you have
very fraught you know international
politics on the other or very fraught
South Asian politics on
the other so my point of departure in
fact is that kind of a question you know
which is that why is it that this
similarity actually doesn't bring us
together rather that they tend to sort
of you know create more and more I think
more and more divides more and more
divisions and raise ugly questions you
know again and again again and again I
mean I'm sort of reminded by I'm sorry
reminded of a statement which the
Earth's Y Z Lankan president in fact of
Sri Lankan Prime Minister Rajapaksa in
fact was talking about it's a good in a
way it's a microcosm kind of argument he
was asked at what is Ceylon cause
problems with India okay and this
question assumes significance because
Sri Lankans relations with China in the
last few years in fact have improved
okay a lot so you'd ask this question
that you know why are you moving closer
to China what's your problem at India so
he gave the answer the answer is
something like this he said that look
with your relatives you will have issues
at times issues which you don't have
between your friends okay so that's an
interesting and sort of an argument okay
but then if you unpack that there is a
lot of social Nadia there's a lot of I
would say anthropology that goes into
the making of it so my take in fact is
that is you know my take is this that if
the state in South Asia are
nation-states but South Asia
historically had been made a state kind
of an entity okay it's always been a
sociological space so what had happened
with the arrival of modern South Asia is
the session between the two the
disjunction of the two so the
territorial logic in fact has almost
virtually colonized the other logic
which is the associate or I would call
the net associative integrative logic of
South Asia and I wish to in a way focus
on the interaction
and then ultimately what do you conclude
in your book well I conclude first and
foremost that as I said at the beginning
that if we have to understand South
Asian politics if we have to understand
India South Asian policy we need to
understand the politics of
territoriality
we need to understand what we are really
you know relate to the institutions of
how we relate to rather to institutions
of sovereignty and how modernity in fact
have reconfigured us okay I mean so
that's the broad in an argument which I
am making in the book so I make the
argument that there are these
alternative politics in India and in
South Asia also so you would have you
know strong cognate Arian politics you
would have you know realists who are
broadly nationally so liberal
nationalists for example and there are
you know a group of radicals who are
mostly based in civil societies and so
therefore unless you know stronger you
know radicals or very strong liberals in
fact they come to dominate the political
imagination of South Asia in general and
Indian particular I do not think that
the politics of South Asia or India's
perception of South Asia as a space
rather in fact is going to change I join
the work of very famous socialists Henry
Lee favor
whose book on state and space and power
in fact had made arguments like you know
we need to understand this this whole
business of state reality very closely
okay so the making of the territory how
the states in fact use these strategies
of Jeju reality and the territorial
effect which means that once you rotate
you realize how does it affect your
thinking so in the South Asian context
in fact I'm trying to you know we
conclude by the fact that we are very
depleted toriel
okay so our thinking in fact is almost
entirely dominated by this notion of
territoriality
they're so depleted in on territorial
that we forget that we were not a
realized formatter for women in much of
our history okay particularly if you're
looking at the colonial times
so broadly I mean this would be the
conclusion that I am making I mean I
take myself as a social scientist that I
have a duty to two facts to empirical
facts and so therefore I put on hold my
own normativity okay you know I do not
say that what exactly is the kind of
politics that I prefer and where
something here should in fact you know
move towards my argument in fact is that
I see certain trends I report those
trends and I try to explain those
strings okay all right very interesting
and your book will be coming out early
next year I don't think it would come
out early next year I I would definitely
be over with the manuscript okay bye-bye
January 2017 and then you know then I
have to find a publisher I've had some
initial talk okay but then it's only
this year as you know when the
manuscript will be weighted so it's a
pretty long process I would be very
happy if it sees the light by the end of
2017 thank you very much it's been a
pleasure thank you for more information
about professor Chatterjee and his
research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale